hey youtubers is Charlie so this is like
week one of the flash being on break
flash and arrow so I thought for my
bonus video I'd do something based on
the Rogues this is mostly gonna focus on
the new characters as they've announced
in the show but that we just haven't met
yet they just cast payton list as Lisa
snart aka golden glider she's captain
cold sister I'm sure Robbie Amell was
pumped to hear that now they can add
Tomorrow People to the list of shows
that they're snagging people from Prison
Break Spartacus and now Tomorrow People
she's not gonna appear till episode 16
but episode 17 the one right after that
is gonna be Mark Hamill's episode he's
gonna be reprising his trickster
character from the original flash series
with a little twist there are a couple
other big rogues they could still bring
on the show because there's still a
couple episodes left they have to cast
but this video is mostly going to be
about heatwave and the other actors
they've already announced so who are the
Rogues if you haven't read the comics
they're like a b-level group of
criminals that band together to commit
crimes in and around Keystone and
Central City the number of rogues at any
given time changes from comic to comic
but there are always a couple core
members that stay the same pretty much
the ones that we're gonna meet on the TV
show those are the core rogues the
oldest ones from the classic comics are
Captain cold
heatwave weather wizard trickster mere
master Pied Piper golden glider
abracadabra and the top some of those
people we have not met yet later in the
comics like the late 1990s early 2000s
they introduced DoubleDown tarpit
plunder girder who we have seen on the
show and murmur the new 52 version of
the Rogues in the comics the most
current version is really close to the
classic roster there have also been
alternate groups like the renegades
which are a future version of their
group from the 25th century with a twist
that there are police task force like
instead of being a group of criminals
they're a group of super cops
interesting sidenote the reverse-flash
the a Oh Bart Thawne reverse-flash is
from the 25th century there was also a
side splinter group called the new
rogues during Final Crisis but that was
created by inertia just to piss off the
original rogues and sup blackmail them
into helping him since the TV show is
still in season one there mostly
sticking with the classic versions of
the characters anytime you're looking
for a rogue
Easter eggs though in the episodes
mostly be looking for stuff from the
classic comics and from Geoff Johns run
that's like everything before an
including flashpoint
so far they've introduced weather wizard
in episode 1 captain cold and heat wave
in episode 4 the post-credits scene from
that episode is where Captain Cold
actually forms the Rogues
officially when he says I'm forming a
new team would you like to join it that
episode is probably one of my favorites
from the first half of the season
Gurdurr debuted in episode six as far as
we know though he died in episode 7
helping them fight blackout Captain
Boomerang who was a big rogue is only
mentioned in the flash vs. arrow
crossover episode they went a little bit
more Suicide Squad with that character
because he's been both a member of
Suicide Squad and the Rogues and then of
course we met the reverse-flash in
episode 9 technically he's not a rope
but a lot of his stories in the comics
get tied up with the Rogues he either
uses them or they cross paths because
they're both trying to take out one of
the flashes like barry allen wally west
bart allen so do not be surprised if by
the end of season 1 or in the finale the
rogues and the reverse-flash appear on
screen together and as far as we know
captain colds gun is the most effective
weapon against him although based on
their fight in episode 9 firestorms
powers work really well against them too
so i should say that if you haven't read
the comics on very rare occasions
Captain Cold has worked with the flash
when it suited him he might be a
criminal but he does live by code I
already did a bonus video about Captain
Cold so I will add a link in the
description if you guys want to watch
this after that but what I'm really
excited about is his sister coming on
the show she had not been confirmed when
they first announced the series
that's who Peyton list is gonna be
playing and she'll probably be playing
Lisa snart their prime I couldn't do
special powers she is like the most
important part of Captain colds life he
turned to a life of crime to support her
like they came from an abusive household
so when they both took off he took it on
himself to support her to keep her safe
that's why he became a bank robber after
he got the cold guns things got a little
crazy but you get the idea I should say
that you know as a character he's not
out to get the flash all he cares about
is his sister pulling heists and
mercenary work are the only viable
options he sees available to him so
meeting Payton list on the show is gonna
be a lot of fun in the comics she became
a rogue in her own right but she's not
so much a criminal like the other
members
since the show's going with the classic
versions of the characters if she does
end up committing any crimes or doing
anything sneaky she's probably gonna
look a little bit more like a cat
burglar you know a la Catwoman the
dynamic between her and Wentworth Miller
it's gonna be so much fun she is kind of
like the voice of reason her character
is really like a calming presence in the
rogue's heatwave though whoo being
played by fellow Prison Break alum
Dominic Purcell is like the flip side of
that he's not related to captain Cole
but they have been friends for most of
their adult lives as the name implies
heat wave is like a powder keg of ego
just waiting to explode he's got an
itchy trigger finger and he is not very
bright so he causes a lot of collateral
damage on all their heists he and
Captain Cold but hits a lot in the
comics Song of Ice and Fire
it's right out of Game of Thrones the
show kind of teased that in Episode four
in that post-credits scene when what
Werth Miller's like I know that last job
didn't go so well as far as we know
they're gonna be the only two rogues in
episode 10 the title of that is actually
really fun it's called revenge of the
Rogues it's just a twist on the comic
book storyline rogues revenge I think
it's a reference in name only just
because rogues revenge was from Final
Crisis it involved Bart Allen or inertia
and a whole bunch of other characters
that we haven't seen yet on the show
it's probably gonna be a story about
their first official mission as the
Rogues our first official heist
Caitlin snow of course being the black
male they're either after STAR Labs Tech
or they want the flash to steal
something for them it's gonna be a lot
of fun
expect Dominic Purcell to go completely
crazy so the next new rogue were
actually gonna meet is Pied Piper he is
the boyfriend of Captain Singh I think I
mentioned him in my last video he's
actually gonna be in two episodes 11 and
12 so he'll be like right after that
rogues revenge story he's a big rogue in
the comic books but the show is changing
his backstory just a little bit to make
him a little more sympathetic and I yeah
I don't think that captain Singh knows
anything about him turning into a
criminal
episode 11 is probably gonna be a teaser
for his character just to introduce him
and then episode 12 will be like his
full-blown revenge story they did tease
the synopsis essentially he's gonna be
like a former STAR Labs employee just
like blackout on the show he's supposed
to be a former STAR Labs employee who's
you know super genius just like everyone
else that works there who went deaf
during the particle accelerator
explosion I'll be interested to see how
they explained the hypnotism and the
Pied Piper aspect of his character one
really trippy thing that I hope that
they include an Easter Egg for
for his character is the anti-life
equation is this really trippy thing
that Jack Kirby invented Grant Morrison
used it a little bit more recently
during Final Crisis it got tied up in
this big dark side' plot it's way too
hard to parse for them to do a storyline
based on it but they might just have an
Easter Egg with a really complicated
equation on a blackboard or something
like that in slightly more practical
matters Mark Hamill is actually gonna be
really exciting episode he's playing the
trickster he's reprising his role from
the original TV series so in the comics
a lot of the Rogues and other B level
villains have more modern versions of
the characters usually the way they
explain it is is there's an old version
of the character that passes the mantle
on to either a son or someone else that
they know on the show that's what's
gonna be happening with the trickster so
Mark Hamill will be like the old
trickster he'll be in iron Heights
prison with John Wesley Shipp which is
actually really awesome supposedly
there's going to be a new imposter
calling himself the trickster and Mark
Hamill's character is gonna help them
take him down I'm crossing my fingers
and really hoping that Mark Hamill gets
a scene with John Wesley Shipp they're
both in iron Heights so it stands to
reason that they'll have some shared
scene in the common room we haven't seen
John Wesley Shipp get a lot of scenes
with other characters outside of Grant
Gustin that's pretty much it for the
Rogues that they've announced so far so
they have 22 episodes in this season
Mark Hamill is episode 17 so they have
about three episodes after that where
they could do mirror master or one of
the other rogues I just don't think that
they're gonna introduce any new
characters in the finale and I do think
that episodes 21 and 22 will be like a
two-part finale even if it's not
officially a two-part episode it's like
usually the last episode before the
finale sets up what's going to happen in
the finale just in terms of other new
villains that they could bring on just
remember that they've used people from
the firestorm comics they've used
Suicide Squad people they kind of pull
from all over generally those the last
couple of episodes are mostly going to
focus on the reverse flash or reverse
flashes I should say I think it was
early March before we learned the titles
for the last couple of episodes for
arrow season 2 so I would expect the
same thing for the flash so if they're
doing any specific comic book storylines
we're not gonna find out for a little
while
just in general I think this season is
closer to rebirth into flashpoint but I
do think we'll see elements from both of
those comics because there is a
time-travel component involved and
multiple reverse flashes I totally love
all the reverse-flash theories that you
guys have pointed out but here's a
couple really
important things to remember when your
theory crafting so one really notable
visible difference between the hunter
zolomon zoom and professor zoom is their
eye coverings so professor zoom doesn't
have anything covering his eye holes
zoom or hunter zolomon have you want to
think about him has lenses and if you
remember the ones stuck in this stasis
field had lenses red lenses covering his
eyes the suit that Harrison wells was
looking at at the end of the episode did
not have eye coverings another important
distinction is that zoom hunters Oh
Lamont was just trying to hurt Barry
Allen professor zoom had a much grander
plan he wanted the ability to shape
reality there was a story not in the
comics where both reverse flashes work
together but because professor zoom
thought the zoom was a douche he dict
him over then he revealed his real plan
to try and get a hold of the Omega
energy that dark-sided infused batman
with whenever he sent it back in time
it's a really complicated storyline but
the takeaway is is that professor zoom
has a much grander vision so just more
things to think about whenever you're
Theory crafting there's still a lot of
stuff about the professor zoom character
that we can talk about and the way he
uses the Speed Force like the abilities
that it gives him but just in general I
do believe Harrison wells is professor
zoom and Eddie Thawne or a future
version of him is zoom is the hunter
zolomon zoom so I am working on an arrow
bonus video Stephen Amell has been
saying all kinds of stuff about the back
half of the season
there's the canary trilogy all kinds of
awesome stuff to talk about so be sure
to subscribe to get that I'm also
working on a hobbit video so I might
post my Hobbit video first and then post
the arrow video right now if you're
watching on a mobile phone or on a
tablet there's new mobile links that you
can click on up here yeah mobile links
is the same as the links over here but
click here for that Captain Cold video
and click here for my mid-season finale
video thank you so much for watching so
that's all high-five
I will see you guys tonight
you